All right, so here is a rule we're
going to call the TD (0) rule,
which gives it a different
name from TD (1).
But eventually we're going to connect
the zero and the one together.
And the rule looks like this,
not so unfamiliar looking.
That the way we're going to
compute our value estimate for
the state that we just left,
when we make a transition at epoch T for
trajectory T, big T,
is what the previous value was.
Plus we're going to move a little bit
in the direction with our learning rate
toward what?
Toward the reward that we observed,
plus the discounted estimated value
of the state that we ended up in,
minus the estimated value of
this state that we just left.
So does this look familiar?
>> It's got Vs, and rs,
and Alphas is in it.
And so- [CROSSTALK]
>> Well sure, all right, but
let's maybe we can be a little
more precise about this.
So what would we expect this outcome
to look like on average, right?
So the thing that's random here,
at least the way we've been talking
about it is, if we were in some
state St-1 and we make a transition,
we don't know what state
we're going to end up in.
But there's some probabilities of those.
So basically this update is being done
more often in the states that we end up
in more often, the more common Sts, and
less often in the Sts that
are less common, or less likely.
And so really if we take the expectation
of this, what is it going to look like?
If we repeat this update over and
over again,
what we're really doing is sampling
different possible St values, right?
So really we're taking an expectation
over what we get as the next state
of the reward plus the discounted
estimated value of that next state.
>> That seems right,
that's kind of what we want.
>> Yeah, so this is exactly what
the maximum likelihood estimate is
supposed to be.
As long as these probabilities for
what the next state is going to be
match what the data has shown so
far as the transition to St.
>> Is that what that blue
stuff above the equations is about?
>> Yeah, so here's the idea, is that if
we repeat this update rule on the finite
data that we've got over and over and
over again, then we're actually taking
an average with respect to how often
we've seen each of those transitions.
So it really is computing
the maximum likelihood estimate.
So this does the right thing.
>> Oh, okay.
So that finite data thing's important
because if we had infinite data,
then everything would work.
>> So right, in the infinite
data case this is also true, but
also TD(1) does the right
thing in infinite data.
>> Kind of everything does
the right thing in infinite data.
>> Yeah, everything's
getting all averaged out, and
it'll do the right thing.
But here we've got a finite
set of data so far.
And the issue is that if we run our
update rule over that data over and
over and over again,
then we're going to get the effect of
having a maximum likelihood model.
And that's not true of
the outcome based model.
Because in the data that we just saw
where we were only saw one transition
from S2 to anything else, we can run
over that over and over and over again.
But the estimate is not going to change,
it's always going to be exactly that.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
Okay, sure, sure, I'll buy that.
>> We can contrast this with the outcome
based idea where we're not doing this
sort of bootstrapping.
We're not using the estimate that
we've gotten at some other state.
We actually use literally
the reward sequence that we saw.
And so as a result of that, if we've
only seen a reward sequence once,
like in the case of S2,
repeating that update over and
over again doesn't change anything.
>> Right, sure, sure, right because
the expectation is the expectation.
>> Right, whereas in here,
we're actually using the intermediate
estimates that we've computed and
refined on all the intermediate nodes.
All the states that we've encountered
along the way to improve our estimate
of the value of every other state,
right?
So this kind of is more self consistent,
It's actually kind of connecting the
values of states to the other values of
the states which is what you'd want.
And this is more just literally
using the experience that it saw and
ignoring the fact that there's
these intermediate states.
>> Okay, well, when you put it that way,
it makes it sound like you should
always use TD(0) and never use TD(1).
>> Yes, but that's oversimplifying.
>> Okay, can you under-simplify it?
>> [LAUGH] We'll get to that.
>> Oh, okay, good, I look forward to it.